this is the Dodge Ram
2021 I'm going to make The Spar key this
spare key or lost key is the same way to
programming so let's see how to do it
with the using nose door so you have to
connect the
cables you know this
cable so first let's see the connect the
cable
here on here just plug it
anywhere just flu anywhere here no
problem just like that flu it and then
show then connect the
cable this cable to the
OBD the
device and other one connect to the
car where are you this here connect here
in the car this it so
now we can go to the
car this is
R so go to the Dodge
first and go
back go to IM remote
go to
dodge select it from
Vel go to
Asia and RAM
1,500 This Is 2020 but the car is 2021
so 2019 2021 is the same
so turn ignition off and high light is
on after
that car is now reading the PIN code
it's automatically read PIN code and pin
code is not showing so you just wait
like a 30 seconds
and make sure that device is connect to
the internet otherwise it's not going to
be program
it so it's read the password is finished
now you have to finish within 60 seconds
just put the smart key into the start
button and push it and keep on pressing
and TW and device will be automatically
showing you that to take out the remote
from the
buttons just keep on
pressing now release the button start
button and press okay that's it now you
can see the car is three keys before was
two keys now is a 3 ke program success
so this is L key or R key is the same
and I checking now remote is working
everything is fine
[Music]